[Música]
a
en mayo en plena primera ola de la
pandemia un informe de naciones unidas y
savethechildren advertía que a finales
de 2020 el 46 por ciento de los menores
de américa latina' podría quedar en
condición de pobreza la pandemia
exacerba la violencia estructural
económica especialmente en los menores
quienes en su condición de población
vulnerable se convierten en una diana
para otros tipos de violencia según
datos de unicef dos de cada tres menores
de 15 años experimentan violencia
doméstica 1 de cada 2
ha sufrido castigos corporales en el
hogar y más allá del hogar en américa
latina hay una tasa de homicidio
adolescente 5 veces más alta que la
media global una violencia que
efectivamente sufren más las niñas con
más de un millón de adolescentes
víctimas de violencia sexual son
indicadores que confirman que américa
latina y caribe es la región del mundo
con mayor índice de maltrato infantil en
dimensiones muy diversas que van desde
el entorno familiar el económico y la
falta de oportunidades pero también por
los efectos derivados de los múltiplos
conflictos en muchos casos armados que
azotan la región
[Música]
se celebra el día internacional del niño
y es una oportunidad para recordar
algunas de las dificultades que enfrenta
la infancia en el continente africano
aproximadamente 400 millones de niños
viven en áfrica
también en el continente se tiene que la
mitad de la población vive bajo la línea
de la pobreza y esto afecta al 30 por
ciento de los niños que están
enfrentando problemas de desnutrición la
educación también es preocupante dado
que 30 millones de niños no pueden ir al
colegio y la mitad de estos son niñas
aplica tiene una de las poblaciones más
jóvenes del mundo y se piensa o se
calcula que en países como angola malí y
níger la mitad de la población tiene
menos de 15 años
áfrica también está pasando por una
etapa en la que tiene un alto índice de
natalidad pero también uno de sus más
altos índices de mortalidad infantil al
mismo tiempo
preocupa también el número de huérfanos
aquí en el sur del continente y también
el alto número de refugiados por
conflictos armados que hay en toda el
áfrica sub-sahariana y cuya mitad de
esta población son menores
[Música]
la región de asia-pacífico presenta una
de las tasas de violencia contra los
niños más altas del mundo según ongs y
organismos internacionales de hecho
según la organización humanitaria world
vision un 64% de los menores de entre 2
y 17 años de la región ha sufrido algún
tipo de abuso físico emocional o sexual
un informe de unicef de 2015 el más
completo que se ha realizado hasta la
fecha destaca que la prevalencia de esta
violencia es más alta en los países
pobres de la región principalmente en el
sudeste asiático
este documento de unicef deja datos
heladores como por ejemplo que en
algunos países hasta un 22 por ciento de
las niñas han sufrido abusos sexuales o
también que en la región casi uno de
cada diez menores ya está trabajando
antes de cumplir los 18 años varios
organismos de defensa de los derechos de
la infancia han destacado además el
incremento de la violencia contra los
menores en el hogar debido a los
confinamientos impuestos por la pandemia
y ha urgido a los gobiernos a que
activen protocolos para evitar esta
situación
[Música]